Bob before we were rolling you told me
quickly that you had an experience where
a woman a stranger total stranger came
up to you right after nine eleven in a
parking lot I had gone to vote that
morning we had a local election I went
into the firehouse I passed the
fireman's TV screen and there was this
image of the World Trade Center and a
plane going into it and we all gate I
went home and called my wife and went to
a store I was in the parking lot of a
store and a woman came up to me a total
stranger and said that's it our lives
will never be the same utterly different
now and she walked away and the rector
said she was absolutely right it's true
we are a different culture now than we
were then we feel more vulnerable and
more aware of all the kinds of dangers
and bad things that could possibly
happen so I do think that's way you know
us as a culture and certainly my
students seem more rum varying concerned
than they were in the 60s also in the
60s it was basically it was much more
prosperous time and getting more bad get
jobs you didn't worry about careers
because those things were around but now
for young people coming out of college
it's a very serious concern and you know
it certainly is for people who are in
the arts it's particularly serious I
have many many students were painters or
sculpture as filmmakers or whatever and
they love what they're doing and then
they save themselves so how am I going
to support myself how am I going to make
a life of this and many of them struggle
and many of them do however somehow find
a way may not be what they thought but
they do find some way to do that and but
it takes courage and strength would you
say that's the number one question you
receive from all your pre graduates what
while they're getting close to finishing
up their last years in college is that
their biggest concern they don't usually
put it in words they put in action
I'll tell you know I sit there and say
okay so what's the next and they begin
to sort of say well you know I don't
quite know I'm worried about that I have
to make some plans I'm looking for this
job and that job so it's certainly on
their minds in a way that I think hasn't
been on people's minds for many many
years that's one of the darker sides of
you know our contemporary life and so
how do you feel that's reflected in the
films that they are making today that
you're even the little things you're
seeing on YouTube and in the the big
studio films how do you feel that that
whole unknown because there really isn't
a set path anymore I know back in even
my time growing up in the 80s you know
if you did a certain you know a B and C
you felt that you were going to get an
outcome from it and I think that all
that is gone it's it's not around so how
do you feel that reflected in there well
I think some of the bitter movies today
express them they move in a fight club
Fight Club seems to me uh turley
unbelievably anxiety provoking and full
of angst and so I do think that films
that do succeed now due to some extent
and articulate that kind of that kind of
thing so they don't actually say to you
I'm scared I'm worried about how am I
going to support myself but you see it
you say interactions because if yeah
people are what's to talk about that
kind of stuff oh you know I do how would
I don't want to make a video about it
well maybe but most people want to sort
of prevail over it mm-hmm and tough it
out sure so it's not something people
talk about very much but honestly you do
feel when you have been around for a
couple of years at different times of
different tempers and this particular
time is troubling what do you feel that
they think it's a weakness on their part
do you see maybe a different level in
let's say Millennials more so than
Generation Xers which is my generation
that maybe they don't want to talk about
anything that's considered weak yes yes
I do
because one wants to be powerful and
once be strong wants to be in control of
one's life and there are so many reasons
nowadays that young people can't do that
or have difficulties sieving simple
things find a way making a living
finding a mate and other sort of level
of disaffiliation of sense your
loneliness that I find my students is
really quite alarming I just wish that
more of them could sort of live happily
with friends and find a kind of
meaningful way for themselves but it's
harder now it's simply it simply has
gotten harder I'm reminded of those
horrible days you know after World War
two when the Italian neo-realist were
making movies and they were making
movies about people struggling on the
street and attempting to sort of make
some sense of their lives after the
world world world world was over and
they couldn't get film and they could
find jobs it'll it was basically
bankrupt so those kinds of things are to
some extent reflected in the world in
general now
you